we have terrifying new video showing
what the mayor of Jersey City New Jersey
calls an anti-semitic hate crime
surveillance camera show two people
firing gun shots into a kosher market on
Tuesday minutes after killing a police
detective three people were killed in
the store the attackers also died during
a shootout with police at lasted hours
two of the victims were buried last
night 24 year-old Moshe Deutsch was
studying to be a rabbi 31 year-old
Mendell Firenze was co-owner of the
store where she was killed Don Dahler is
at the scene in Jersey City with more on
this story Don it's so disturbing and
heartbreaking when you hear what
happened there on Tuesday what else are
we learning about this case it really
really is Gail it's so sad and this is a
community in fear investigators now say
that the two shooters were a couple who
had possible ties to what some people
consider a hate group yesterday the
police chief told us that were it not
for the two officers who were nearby
heard the shots and responded so quickly
more people could have died newly
released surveillance video reveals the
moment a man and woman pulled up to the
grocery store in a stolen rental van got
out and started firing Jersey City mayor
Steven Fulop says it's clear they
targeted the kosher market from our
standpoint there is no question that
this is a hate crime Sam gold was
trapped in his car while shots whizzed
by him some bullets hit his vehicle he
was finally able to escape when officers
arrived on the scene he did not want us
to show his face on camera it took 25
minutes I was laying in my car bullets
on top of my head I was kid every second
that a bullet is gonna go through my car
David Lacs is the man seen running from
the store he says he came face-to-face
with the shooters he spoke to us on the
phone but that's a way to look at me boy
they came in they came to kill this was
the scene inside the grocery the walls
riddled with large bullet holes three
innocent victims were found dead in the
store Rabbi Moshe Shapiro's says this
attack comes as a shock there's a
growing community here of Orthodox Jews
who have settled in this area it's a
very diverse area have you sensed any
tensions because of that
I have not a visitor all the time a
frequentist synagogue and the grocery
store and we never see they never
complain of any local attacks the
killers were also found dead in a store
they were identified as 47 year old
David Andersson and fifty year old
Francine Graham investigators believe
the supposed couple identified in the
past as black Hebrew Israelites a group
known to rail against whites and jews
they began to shoot out at the Bay View
Cemetery early Tuesday afternoon where
they shot and killed Jersey City
detective Joe seals when we lose cops
it's always difficult but when you lose
somebody is activist Joe everybody knew
him because he was out there all the
time chasing crime all the time New
Jersey's Attorney General says a pipe
bomb was found in that u-haul that the
shooters used now currently state and
federal agents are leading this
investigation another press conference
is scheduled for later today we hope to
get some more information
Anthony Dunn and a reminder that police
officer have five children Thank You Don